[Music]  New Year's rockin Eve co-host Jenny  McCarthy is sounding off on the Mariah  Carey performance debacle Mariah's pre  midnight medley of hits looked like a  technical disaster and it's turned into  a he-said she-said debate of blame  between Mariah's team and Dick Clark  Productions a source tells et Mariah was  so upset with post and executive  producer Ryan Seacrest for not stepping  in to help but she couldn't even stand  it next to him to watch the ball drop  well here's what Ryan's co-host Jenny  had to say about it on her Sirius XM  show Tuesday morning and I felt really  bad for her it was a complete train  wreck my sympathy stopped however the  moment she accused Dick Clark  Productions of sabotaging her  performance if Dick Clark were alive  today I guarantee he would be on air  right now fighting back he's not so I'm  going to Dick Clark Productions has been  doing this show for 45 years for her to  defame them was so incredibly insulting  [Music]  you